foreign
to build a better planet
benefited half of this room more
what if we reduced our missions but
increased the gap between men and women
what if by 2050 we reached Net Zero but
women had a lower chance than men to
find a decent job
disturbing right
and yet this is exactly what my
colleagues and I found while studying
the links between women and climate over
the last years
our research has shown that climate
action as it is unfolding could set
gender equality back by 15 years
I'm gonna say that again
so climate action not climate change
climate action meaning all the efforts
that are being made to reduce our
emissions to adapt Our Lives to a warmer
planet
could actually set gender equality back
by 15 years
I know what you must be thinking
this is a total vascale
so the climate challenge is not big
enough you're adding solving gender
equality to the equation
I get the feeling but the good news is
if we do it right we have a unique
chance to advance both the climate's
agenda and gender equality
how by being intentional about it
but first let's go back to that 15-year
setback risk I mentioned I give it to
you it's counter-intuitive to say that
climate action that aims at building a
more viable future to all of us could
actually have a negative impact on
gender equality so let me explain
obviously women as well as men women
even more than men will benefit from
living in a more
sustainable Planet their heads their
education their livelihoods will improve
but what I'm saying is that there is
also a risk that women might miss out on
the green economies massive Investments
and job opportunities
and here are two examples of that
by 2030 65 million green jobs will be
created the highest paid more stable
ones will require what's called stem
education science technology engineering
mathematics
today women represent 35 of stem
students globally
so they might be less qualified to
access these green jobs
second example
by 2030 companies in highly emitting
sectors such as energy building
materials industrial goods will be
spending as much as 500 billion dollars
to train their employees in new green
skills
now these industries are historically
male dominated so mechanically women are
less likely to participate in these
retrainings widening the skill gap
between men and women again in accessing
the jobs of the future
so see the risk is real women might miss
out on these opportunities and
Investments or at least miss out on part
of them
even if this wasn't the initial intent
so what is it that we
need to do to have a climate action that
solves these two major challenges at the
same time gender equality and
sustainability
well we need to do something that seems
very simple yet very often overlooked
when investing in green projects and
developing green products crafting green
legislations we need to make sure that
women as well as men will equally
benefit
not more not less just
equally
might seem obvious you might even think
isn't that what we're already doing
but history has showed us that time and
time again even though this is what we
think we're doing this is not what is
actually happening at least not
naturally organically not without an
explicit intent so we need to take this
intent Into Climate action we need to
naturally systematically
intentionally embed what you could call
a gender lens in all of the green
economies Investments projects and
legislations and I am not just talking
about projects targeting women or funds
dedicated to women or a gender day in
climate negotiations I am talking about
gender as an intentional forethought in
every Green project every Green
investment every Green legislation
let's take an example green cities
green cities are a great illustration of
how we could
integrate these gender lands and have
climate action boost gender equality
instead of setting it back
from Chicago to Shanghai from Copenhagen
to Rio most large cities have ambitious
programs to become greener
two trillion dollars will have to be
spent every year for the next 20 years
to upgrade Urban infrastructure and make
it more sustainable
and this covers housing energy
safety public transportation green
spaces you name it
with the rights approach these cities
can become Greener and more inclusive of
women
now Greener they sort of know how to do
that they have already initiated
multiple projects and there is already a
lot of research in that field
but becoming more inclusive of women
we hear less about that this is less
documented
and yet there is a great story that can
serve as an inspiration
this story takes place in the beautiful
city of Vienna in Austria
in the 90s planning officials in Vienna
realized that
women were less satisfied with
transportation systems than men
because these systems are designed for
people going between home and work
between suburbs and City centers at
mostly set times
but women although they make up the
majority of public transportation users
women's trips are nothing like that they
are much more fragmented they are much
shorter they require multiple
Transportation modes and they don't
necessarily happen during rush hour
all of this because women combine their
work trips with their domestic and
caregiving responsibilities
and this transportation is a major
factor when it comes to women's labor
and participation to the economy
they also noticed something else before
the age of nine boys and girls would
equally go to parks
but when girls reached the age of nine
something strange happens
they almost disappeared from public
parks
so they did some research and they
confirmed that no it's not that all of a
sudden when girls turn nine they no
longer are interested in public parks
it's again because of the way these
parks are designed with their single
large open space and multiple football
cages boys feel welcomed girls feel they
need to compete for space
so so they just stopped going there so
bottom line through these two examples
and many more they realized that the
gender neutral approach that the city
had and that most cities in the world
have
this gender neutral approach can
actually be a women blind one
so they decided to intentionally design
a gender equal urban planning program
so they surveyed men and women to better
understand the way they live in the city
they brought in female Architects and
urban planners to participate alongside
their maid colleagues to participate to
the city's redesign
they added gender assessment in social
housing and infrastructure contract so
see just like that in every step where
every step was made with the intention
the explicit intention to make sure that
women will benefit
as well as men again not more not less
as well as men so in Parks they have
added Foods paths to divide up space
they have integrated a wider range of
activities such as volleyball
and just like that teenage girls came
back to parks
and this has benefited teenage girls but
not only them
every year since 2009 except for
co-videos Vienna has been named the best
city in the world to live in
now it's not just the gendered approach
but it clearly contributed because For
the First Time the specific needs of the
other help of the population were taken
into account
now what does Vienna's story tell us it
tells us that if we want women to
benefit from a green city project
from an urbanism project or from any
project it needs intention
an intention means at least these three
ingredients
upfront understanding women specific
needs even if the project is not
specifically targeting women
involving women in the design of the
project
and specifically measuring the impact of
the project on women to be able to
adjust if necessary
so this way with this approach we could
correct the biases that are behind the
gender neutral urban planning
programs that exist everywhere and we
could duplicate Vienna's intentional
experience in every Green City
and I left the best part for the end
when involved in urban planning women
proved to be active agents of
sustainability
statistically the most sustainable
cities are also the ones with the
highest representation of women in
policy making and Leadership positions
so this gendered approach will not only
make green CC's more inclusive of women
it will also make them greener
treating women exactly like men as I
have heard
multiple times from policy makers and
leaders is not what will get us to
gender equality because it turns a blind
eye to the biases that we all have
and it tends to perpetuate pre-existing
inequalities and could even be widening
them
urbanism is just one example of how the
green economy will revolutionize the way
we move work
eat if we intentionally embed a gender
lens in the way we will sustainably
rebuild rethink all of these aspects we
can advance gender equality at the same
time and this will in turn have a
positive impact on the planet
see we can't save the world almost once
after all
thank you
[Applause]